rumor has it that starfield could be
fully revealed
this year yes this year for those who
may not know what i'm talking about
starfield is the next big project from
the team that brought you skyrim
skyrim legendary edition skyrim vr
skyrim special edition and skyrim very
special edition
now skyrim and life become
one a mud crab scuttles toys rhoda i
didn't catch that
face i didn't quite catch those thanks
your shout echoes all the way to
sovengaard as of this recording we don't
know much about starfield
other than it's an open world maybe open
worlds single-player rpg
that takes place in outer space the team
at bethesda game studios has been
dropping hints for the last couple years
but we don't have a lot to go off of
would it be weird to say the word
starfields in front of people would you
just say
you gotta watch that man someone will
hear you so i decided it might be fun to
make a list of the top 7 things we want
todd howard to wear
next time he takes the stage at e3
[Music]
just kidding here are the top 7 things
we want to see in starfield
[Music]
[Music]
number one an engine overhaul this is
already happening but i knew i had to
include it according to god howard in an
interview for the develop brighton
conference
this engine overhaul will be a huge leap
forward
according to todd bigger than the jump
from morrowind to oblivion to quote the
man himself
from rendering to animation to pathing
to procedural generations i don't want
to say everything but
it's a significant significant overhaul
hopefully this also means we won't be
hit with as many loading screens
procedural generation really stands out
here though this could mean
a procedurally generated solar system or
universe for the player to explore
or it could mean better procedurally
generated quests like the radiant quests
we saw in skyrim
either way it sounds like starfield is
incredibly ambitious in terms of engine
tech
number two a real ass rpg or at least
close to one
the term rpg gets thrown around a lot
when it comes to video games
these days all you need to be an rpg is
a level up system
some skill trees and maybe a character
creator but in my mind an
rpg means you can be who you want to be
and play how you want to play early
bethesda games like daggerfall and
morrowind really excelled at this but
fallout 4 kinda forced you into being a
parent it was a cool setup for a first
playthrough but i never really felt
compelled to return to that world
because i felt like i needed to follow
the game's story
not my own for starfield i hope the
world and story are a lot more malleable
if i play as a starship engineer let me
defeat the big bad threat by disabling
their ship
or something like that i don't know i
just don't want to shoot my way through
every encounter think new vegas and
space
like outer worlds but not outer worlds
and not to be confused with the other
space game outer wilds
although if you clicked this video and
you haven't played outer worlds you
should probably stop what you're doing
and play outer worlds
and outer wilds number three better ai
this is a big one for me arguably one of
the most dated aspects of all the more
recent bethesda game studios games is
its ai
characters constantly repeat dialogue
their pathing breaks often
most enemies just rush the player and
sometimes npcs don't always react
appropriately
apart from bugs broken and or janky ai
is usually the immersion breaking
culprit for me
it's a shame too because oblivion felt
like such a huge leap forward when it
came to ai but i feel like
not much has changed in the 15 years
since with starfield i hope we see a
more responsive and dynamic ai
believable npc routines with logical
responses to the player's buffoonery
could go a long way
think red dead redemption 2's ai but in
space
number 4 better combat alright you knew
this was coming i feel like with every
new game
bethesda game studios gets incrementally
better at combat at least when it comes
to shooting
melee combat though oh boy now
considering starfield is a sci-fi game
i'm sure you'll be doing a lot of
shooting but if
there is melee combat it needs an
overhaul desperately
i am so tired of swinging at air at the
very least there needs to be
more impact i'd also love to see
moment-to-moment fight mechanics like
parries counters and reposts
as for the shooting i feel like more
mobility could work wonders
right now when i play fallout all i do
is backpedal and shoot
it sucks say what you want about
cyberpunk 2077
well don't actually i'm very tired of
cyberpunk takes but the mobility and
double jump upgrade made the combat in
that game a hell of a lot more
interesting
number five spaceships let me fly a
spaceship please
but also let me fast travel when i don't
want to fly a spaceship
thanks todd number six a modder's
paradise
the biggest reason i still play bethesda
games to this day
is for the mods don't get me wrong i
love these janky games i happily put in
hundreds of hours in oblivion fallout 3
skyrim and fallout 4 at launch but the
reason i come back years later is
because of the modding community the
work the community has done over the
years is nothing short of incredible
i know todd and the team at bethesda
knows this but i just want to reiterate
it here
empower the community
number seven no more bugs unless they
are really funny
in this world nothing is certain except
death taxes and buggy bethesda games in
a perfect world starfield would be bug
free but this world isn't perfect there
will be bugs but at the very least i
hope bethesda manages to iron out all
the game breaking bugs
i feel like whenever a game of this
scope comes out three days after launch
some kid on reddit had all his data
wiped because he saved his game in the
wrong place at the wrong time
so with that said less bad bugs more
good bugs like this one
well there are seven things i want to
see in starfield if there's something i
missed let us know in the comments below
or you can find me on twitter at jacob
deck if you enjoyed this video and are
thinking
hey i'd like to see another video this
guy made you should check out my video
on oblivion 15 years later that's right
oblivion is 15 years old you're welcome
[Music]
you